[Music]
it was a big day for movie news we got a
new teaser for Deadpool - not on my
watch mother and a seriously magical
music video for John Legend and Ariana
Grande's Beauty and the Beast
[Music]
back to Deadpool we see Wade Wilson up
to his usual antics he spots a man being
robbed and bolts for a phone booth to do
a quick change
brace yourself we see more Deadpool than
we bargained for Wow nice suit fit
family also pay attention to that
graffiti Nathan summers coming soon a
nod to the character cable who will
appear in the highly anticipated sequel
oh Jesus
oh that's not good what is good is the
new Beauty and the Beast music video not
only do we see John Legend and ariana
grande in regal movie themed attire we
see Belle and the Beast enjoying a
romantic dance
[Music]
me
[Music]
et was with legend at the film's
premiere last week he gushed over being
able to revive the iconic song we're
happy to do this song original film
original song and for us to be able to
recreate it's been fun
you